[Musique]
oui de sharon près de la bastille le
faire et la brique envahissent même le
vieux faubourg saint-antoine où les
artisans du bois se serrent les uns
contre les autres
depuis si longtemps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'occasion d'un feu rouge on découvre
encore à paris des mastodontes superbe
abandonné au milieu des voitures
ce sont les traces visibles d'une
archéologie industrielle qui reste à
faire
sur le quai de la gare en face des
entrepôts de bercy au sud de paris dans
le xiiie arrondissement
au bord de la seine se décharger le
charbon les chevaux des tombereaux
entrer dans le fleuve jusqu'aux poitrail
une femme commandait la manoeuvre elle
avait un grand fouet à la main
[Musique]
des tonnes de charbon entassent élèves
une usine d'air comprimé est construite
en 1891
chef-d'oeuvre du fer et de la brique ce
monument conserve sa destination
première
80 ans après
[Musique]
cheap que
de gaston guiraud le personnel actif se
composait essentiellement de machiniste
de chauffeurs de manoeuvre et
dégraisseurs trois machines géantes
actionné par une force de 3000 chevaux
capter l'air et au moyen de compresseur
puissant transformer ce mélange
d'oxygène et d'azoté assez kg de
pression
projeté dans des canalisations ses
terres récupérées en force faisaient le
même travail que la vapeur
il alimentait les moteurs des petites
cuisines disséminés dans la capitale
ainsi que les horloges pneumatiques des
grandes artères parisiennes dans cette
usine jeu fut embauché en qualité de
manoeuvre puis jeu devint par la suite
chauffeurs et conducteurs de machines
électriques
le travail était pénible et journée
longue
[Musique]
le
où
[Musique]
m
rue louis blanc
près du canal saint martin
les cadres de l'industrie loge dans le
centre de la ville
tout le pari construit entre 1850 et
1914 est un pari bourgeois un pari en
pierre traditionnel quelquefois pompeux
[Musique]
l'avant-garde architectural est liée à
la production
le fer et le verre trouve plus
facilement leur emploi par les
ingénieurs que par les architectes
fidèle à la pierre de taille au
chapiteau et aux cariatides
où
[Musique]
e
la main de l'artisan n'en perd pas ses
droits pour autant une main d'oeuvre
qualifiée de chaudronnier ferronnier et
serrurier
[Musique]
le
m
[Musique]
ainsi est né un nouveau paysage parisien
maisons et usines se succédaient le long
du canal saint martin mais il ne reste
plus que ce gros animal noir là bas de
travers silencieux dans le mugissement
des voitures sur le quai
quai de jemmapes entre la république et
jaurès
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un garage c'était
autrefois une des premières centrales de
la compagnie parisienne d'électricité
[Musique]
oh
le
[Musique]
vous
et
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des colonnes de faire des gages de
larges volumes pour les grosses machines
de l'époque
[Musique]
quelque part cela prend même la lure
d'une salle hypostyle égyptienne
[Musique]
c'est une architecture d'une flexibilité
étonnante conçu pour des usages
industriels
elle est prête à toutes sortes de
mutation et elle permettrait à réemploi
facile de ces grands espaces libres dans
un gymnase une école un théâtre ou
pourquoi pas dans un musée de
l'architecturé industrielle
[Musique]
e
vous
[Musique]
donc
oui
[Musique]
une machine permettait de hisser le
charbon par le monte charge dans des
wagonnets
[Musique]
la nouvelle fée électricité est né ici
qui devait transformer paris en ville
lumière
[Musique]
de grandes baies vitrées aménagé entre
des poutrelles de fer trous les façades
des ateliers de couture
[Musique]
je vais organiser ma nourriture de la
façon suivante le matin je prenais un
pain de 5 centimes et 5 centimes de
l'est soit 10 centimes pour mon petit
déjeuner à midi je prenais mon repas
avec les ouvriers de l'atelier et là je
ne voulais pas avoir l'air de me priver
je prenais donc un ordinaire de 50
centimes composé de boeuf bouilli avec
légumes et du bouillon
je mangeais le bouillon dans lequel je
m'étais quantité de pain puis les
légumes et je gardais le boeuf pour
l'histoire mémoire de jeanne bouvier la
misère rôde dans la rue ainsi en février
1895 autour du gymnase japy près de la
place voltaire entre nation et
république
l'oeuvre charitable de la bouchée de
pain la salle est vaste très propres ont
fait asseoir les misérables sur des
bancs et parmi eux je remarque deux
nouvelles recrues bien digne d'attirer
l'attention
l'une est une dame assez élégamment
vêtues à laquelle la brave préposé aux
distributions croit devoir dire est ce
par simple curiosité que vous venez
madame dans ce cas vous devriez ne pas
diminuer la part de ceux qui ont faim
j'ai faim répondre simplement la
malheureuse
j'ai demandé à cette pauvre femme la
cause de son infortune elle m'a dit être
artiste peintre et avoir été reçu deux
fois au salon néanmoins son métier ne la
fait pas vivre et le meurent de faim
[Musique]